you see what is happening I think is
it's it's really bigger than
psychedelics
it's bigger than human evolution we are
not making the waves in this ocean we
are our quarks riding the waves of the
ocean but we are privileged by perhaps
chance alone to occupy a unique moment
in the history of the universe a moment
when the universe goes through some kind
of self transforming evolutionary
inflationary expansion that's what's
happening and so the whisperings that
reach the ears of the Chandler's the
visions that come through the hands of
painters sculptors choreographers
musicians all of the felt presence of
the invisible world is now incredibly
pregnant with this message of
transformation and the challenge for
each of us is to streamline our language
sufficiently that we may mirror this
thing in a way that is both true to it
and rationally apprehend able to
ourselves and this is a fractal boundary
this is a test of intelligence because
the thing in itself cannot be rationally
beheld
you know the entomologist JBS Haldane
once said he said the world is not only
strong
and we suppose if stranger than we can
suppose back to me is a dizzying thought
and obviously true so what we wanted a
marble true to the stranger than we can
suppose but not so alien that there is
no emotional or spiritual support in it
for the enterprise of being human how do
we do that how do we inculcate the
unspeakable mystery of the
transcendental object at the end of time
with the mundane Nexus of real occasions
that happens to be our own existence to
my mind the answer is it lies in the
ability to assimilate paradox and that
means you have to transcend the idea of
a closed logical system you have to live
with the idea that there is no
intellectual closure that this is in
fact the door marked freedom but you've
been taught that it's the door marked
madness
to live in the light of paradox things
cannot be we are taught both a and B
simultaneously this is Aristotelian
logic a is a this is as old as thought
in the West but it has to be overcome
and in the felt presence of the moment
of immediate experience it is overcome
the mystery does not lie far it lies in
the immediate moment in the in the act
the fact of being so the challenge to
all of us I think is not this
one-dimensional chasing after of answers
this is a fool's inning but an actual
stepping back to gain perspective and to
realize you know salvation is always
available it's in the moment it's an act
of understanding it doesn't come down
through an image it doesn't come through
a substance an empowerment award it
comes through understanding
but the salvation is an act of rational
apprehension of some sort
[Music]